This episode of Real Engineering is brought
to you by Brilliant.
A problem solving website that teaches you
to think like an engineer.
Last month Tesla held an event for their investors
revealing the advances they had made in their
autonomous driving capabilities.
Currently, most Tesla vehicles are capable
of enhancing the driver's abilities.
It can take over the tedious task of maintaining
lanes on highways , monitor and match the
speeds of surrounding vehicles and can even
be summoned to you while you aren’t in the
vehicle.
Those capabilities are impressive and in some
cases even life-saving, but it is still a
far reach from a full self-driving vehicle.
Requiring regular input from the driver to
ensure they are paying attention and capable
of taking over when needed.
There are 3 primary challenges automakers
like Tesla, need to overcome in order to succeed
in replacing the human driver.
The first of those is building a safe system
In order to replace human drivers, the self-driving
car needs to be safer than a human driver.
So how do we quantify that?
We can’t guarantee accidents won’t occur.
Old Murphy’s Law is always in play.
We can start by quantifying how safe human
drivers are.
In the US, the current fatality rate is about
one death per one million hours of driving.
That includes humans being stupid and crashing
while drunk or looking at their phone, so
we can probably hold our vehicles to a higher
standard.
But that can be our benchmark for now, our
self-driving vehicle needs to fail less than
once every one million hours, and currently,
that is not the case.
[1]
We do not have enough data to calculate an
accurate statistic here, but we do know that
Uber’s self driving vehicle needed a human
to intervene around every 19 kilometres s,
meaning it failed every 13 miles.
[13] Which makes Ubers collision with a pedestrian
who unfortunately passed away, even more shocking.
Supporters of self-driving vehicles were quick
to blame the pedestrian for stepping in front
of the vehicle in low light conditions [2],
but we cannot let our desire to advance the
technology to make excuses for it.
The vehicle was using lidar sensors which
do not need light to see.
Yet, it made no attempt to slow down even
after the human occupant, who was not paying
attention, had noticed the imminent crash.
According to data obtained from Uber, the
vehicle first observed the pedestrian 6 seconds
before impact with its radar and lidar sensors.
At this point it was travelling at 70 kilometres
per hour [3].
It continued at this speed.
As the pedestrian and vehicles paths converged
the computers classifying system is seen struggling
to identify what the object in its view is.
Jumping from unidentified object to car, to
cyclist.
With no certainty in the trajectory path of
the object.
1.3 seconds before the crash the vehicle recognised
it needed to perform an emergency brake, but
didn’t as it was programmed not to break
if the would result in a deceleration over
6.5 metres per second squared.
Instead, the human operator is expected to
intervene, but the vehicle was not designed
to alert the driver.
A shocking design considering our earlier
statistic.
The driver did intervene a second before impact
by engaging the steering wheel and breaking,
bringing the vehicle speed to 62 kilometres
per hour.
Too little and too late to save this person.
Nothing on the vehicle malfunctioned.
Everything worked as programmed, it was simply
poor programming.
Here the internal computer was clearly not
programmed to deal with uncertainty.
Where a human would likely slow down when
confronted with something on the road that
it could not clearly identify, this programme
simply continued on until it could identify
the threat, at which point it was too late.
It struggled to identify the object and predict
it’s path even with high resolution lidar.
So how can we improve safety?
A large part of that lies in the hardware
itself and the programming that goes into
it.
Tesla unveiled its new purpose-built computer,
a chip specifically optimized for running
a neural network, which Elon stated was the
first of its kind.
[https://youtu.be/Ucp0TTmvqOE?t=6031]
It has been designed to be retrofitted into
existing vehicle s when customers purchase
the full self-driving upgrade.
So is a similar size and draws the same power
as the existing self- driving computers at
100 Watts [4]
This has increased Tesla’s self driving
computer’s capabilities by 2100%.
Allowing it to process 2300 frames per second,
2190 frames more than their previous iteration.
A massive performance jump, and that processing
power will be needed to analyse footage from
the suite of sensors each new Tesla has.
On the right side of the board are all connectors
for the different sensors and cameras in the
car.
That currently consists of 3 forward facing
cameras, all mounted behind the windshield.
One is a 120-degree wide angle fisheye lens,
which gives situational awareness.
Capturing traffic lights and objects moving
into the path of travel.
The second camera is a narrow-angle lens which
provides longer range information needed for
high speed driving like on a motorway, and
the third is the main camera, which sits in
the middle between these two applications.
There are 4 additional cameras on the sides
of the vehicle which check for vehicles unexpectedly
entering your lane and provide the information
needed to safely enter intersections and change
lane.
The 8th and final camera is located to the
rear, which doubles as a parking camera, but
has also saved more than a few teslas from
being rear-ended.
*cut to footage of Tesla speeding up autonomously
to avoid a crash*
The vehicle does not completely rely on visual
cameras.
It also makes use of 12 ultrasonic sensors
which provide a 360-degree picture of the
immediate area around the vehicle, and 1 forward
facing radar.
[5]
Finding the correct sensor fusion has been
a subject of debate among competing self-driving
companies.
Musk recently stated that anyone relying on
Lidar sensors, which works similarly to radar
but utilizes light instead of radio waves,
is doomed and that it’s a fool’s errand.
To see why he said this let’s plot the strengths
of each sensor on a radar chart like this,
where we rank each feature on a scale of zero
to five, five being the best and zero being
non-existent.
Lidar would look something like this.
[6] It’s got great resolution, meaning it
provides high detail information on what it’s
detecting.
Works in the low and high light situations,
is capable of measuring speed, has good range,
and works moderately well in poor weather
conditions.
Its biggest weakness however is why Musk slated
it.
The sensors are expensive and bulky.
And this is where the second challenge of
building a self-driving car comes into play.
Building an affordable system that the average
person will be willing to buy.
Lidar sensors are those big sensors you see
on Waymo, Uber and most competing self-driving
tech.
Musk is more than aware of Lidars potential,
after all Space X utilizes it in their dragon
eye navigation sensor.[9] It’s weaknesses
are simply too much of a sticking point for
Tesla for now, who are focused on building
not just a cost-effective vehicle, but a good
looking vehicle.
Lidar technology is gradually becoming smaller
and cheaper.
Making the technology more accessible, but
far from cheap.
Waymo, a subsidiary of Google’s parent company
Alphabet, sells its lidar sensors to any company
that does not compete with its plans for a
self-driving taxi service.
When they started in 2009 the per unit cost
of a Lidar sensor was around seventy-five
thousand dollars, but they have managed to
reduce that cost to seventy-five hundred dollars
in the past ten years by manufacturing the
units themselves.
[7]
From what I can tell.
Waymo vehicles use 4 lidar sensors on each
side of the vehicle.
Placing the total cost for just these sensors,
for a third party, at thirty thousand dollars.
Not far off the total cost of a base model
Model 3.
This sort of pricing clearly doesn’t line
up with Tesla’s mission “To accelerate
the world’s transition to sustainable transport”.
[8]
This issue has pushed Tesla towards a cheaper
sensor fusion set up.
Let’s look at the strengths and weakness
of the 3 other sensor types to see how Tesla
is making do without lidar.
First, let's look at radar.
This is the radar sensor on the Tesla Model
3.
Radar works wonderfully in all conditions.
The sensors are small and cheap, capable of
detecting speed, and its range is good for
both short and long distance detection.
Where they fall is the low-resolution data
they provide, but this weakness can easily
be augmented by combining it with cameras.
Regular video cameras look like this on our
radar chart.
Having excellent range and resolution, provide
colour and contrast information for reading
street signs, and are extremely small and
cheap.
Combining radar and cameras allows each to
cover the weakness of the other.
We are still a little weak in proximity detection,
but using two cameras in stereo can allow
the cameras to work like our eyes to estimate
distance.
When fine tuned distance measurement is needed
we can use our our ultrasonic sensors, which
are these little circular sensors dotted around
the car.
This gives us solid performance all around
without relying on large and expensive sensors,
but Tesla is suffering from a bit of a redundancy
problem with only one forward facing radar.
If that fails there isn’t a second radar
sensor to rely upon.
This is a cost effective solution, and according
to Tesla their hardware is already capable
of allowing their vehicles to self-drive.
Now they just need to continue improving on
the software and Tesla is in a fantastic position
to make it work.
When training a neural network data is key.
Waymo has millions of kilometres driven to
gain data, but Tesla has over a billion.
33% of all driving with Teslas is with autopilot
engaged.
This data also extends past just while autopilot
is engaged.
It also receives data in areas where autopilot
is not available, like city streets.
Accounting for all the unpredictability of
driving requires an immense amount of training
for a machine learning algorithm, and this
is where Tesla’s data gives them an advantage.
I won’t go through the intricacies of training
a neural network again, as I have covered
it in the past in my machine learning versus
cancer video, but the key take away you need
is that the more data you have to train a
neural network, the better it’s going to
be.
Tesla’s machine vision does a decent job
of it, but there are plenty of gaps in their
abilities.
A channel here on YouTube by the name of “Greentheonly”
has managed to hack into his Tesla’s vision
to show us what the software actually sees.
Here we can see that the software places bounding
boxes around objects it detects, while categorising
them as cars, trucks, bicycles and pedestrians.
It labels each with a relative velocity to
the vehicle and what lane is occupies.
It highlights drivable areas, marks the lane
dividers and sets a projected path between
them.
For now this data allows autopilot to operate
on highways, but it frequently struggles with
more complicated scenes.
Here a pedestrian is not detected.
Here it struggles to tell if a roller skater
is a bike or a pedestrian, and here it drives
onto the wrong side of the road when there
is a gap in lane dividers.[12]
Tesla of course is more than aware of these
problems, and is gradually improving on it’s
software through firmware updates.
Adding functionality like stop line recognition.
And this latest self driving computer is going
to radically increase the computer's processing
power.
Which allow Tesla to continue adding functionality
without jeopardising refresh rates of information.
But even if they manage to develop the perfect
computer vision, programming the vehicle on
how to handle every scenario is another hurdle.
This is a vital part of building not only
a safe vehicle, but a practical self -driving
vehicle.
Which is our third challenge.
Programming for safety and practicality often
conflict with each other.
Take the AI program Dr. Tom Murphy developed
to do something relatively simple.
To play Tetris.
[10]
This program worked brilliantly, but Tetris
always wins.
The game is unbeatable, and you will eventually
lose.
When confronted with this option the program
did something to ensure it wouldn’t lose.
It paused the game.
If we program a vehicle purely for safety.
It’s safest option is to not drive.
Driving is an inherently dangerous operation,
and programming for the multitude of scenarios
that can arise while driving is an insanely
difficult task.
It’s easy to say “Follow the rules of
the road and you will do fine”, but the
problem is, humans don’t follow the rules
of the road perfectly.
Take a simple four way stop as an example.
The rules of the road make this seem like
an easy task.
The first person to arrive at the intersection
has the right of way, and in the case that
two vehicles arrive at the same time.
The vehicle to the right has the right of
way.
The problem is, no human follows these rules.
When Google began testing their driverless
cars in 2009 this was just one of the issues
they ran into.
[11] When it arrived at one of these 4 way
junctions humans kept nudging forward trying
to make their way onto the junction before
their turn.
The Google car was programmed to follow the
letter of the law, and just like our Tetris
program from earlier, the self-driving vehicle
was put in a no-win scenario and stuck on
pause.
Scenarios like this pop up everywhere and
requires programmers to break the letter of
the law and be a little aggressive.
Sometimes the computer will need to make difficult
decisions, and may at times need make a decision
that endangers the life of its occupants or
people outside of the vehicle.
That is just a natural byproduct of an inherently
dangerous task, but if we continue improving
on the technology we could start to see road
deaths plummet, while making taxi services
drastically cheaper and freeing many people
from the financial burden of purchasing a
vehicle.
Tesla is in a fantastic position to gradually
update their software as they master each
scenario.
They don’t need to create the perfect self-driving
car out of the gate, and with this latest
computer they are going to be able to continue
improving their technology.
This is the fantastic thing about software.
It is easily updatable, and Brilliant have
improved their software by allowing courses
to be downloaded for offline use on iOS, so
you can work on learning new things even on
an underground train or a plane.
Brilliant also recently released their fantastic
course on Python coding called Programming
with Python.
Python is one of the most widely used programming
languages, and it is an excellent first language
for new programmers.
It can be used for everything from video games
to data visualization to machine learning
for self driving vehicles.
This course will show you how to use Python
to create intricate drawings, coded messages
and beautiful data plots, while teaching you
some essential core programming concepts.
This is just one of many courses on Brilliant.
They also just released a Computer Science
Essentials course, and have many more due
to released soon on things like Electricity
and Magnetism.
If I have inspired you and you want to educate
yourself, then go to brilliant.org/RealEngineering
and sign up for free.And the first 500 people
that go to that link will get 20% off the
annual Premium subscription, so you can get
full access to all their courses as well as
the entire daily challenges archive.
As always thanks for watching and thank you
to all my Patreon supporters.
If you would like to see more from me the
links to my instagram, twitter, subreddit
and discord server are below.